bien mesdames et messieurs après les
salutations ultramarines
je vous adresse les salutations normande
et il y a peut-être le reblochon
mais il ya aussi le camembert le livarot
le pont l'évêque et je vous rappelle que
nous sommes la région où il y a le plus
ce prix là vous notre candidat nous
sommes en normandie
pardon de le dire à la région auvergne
rhône-alpes
nous sommes la région où il ya le plus
de signes de qualité et d'akoupé et dao
c est mon cher laurent si tu veux
quelques leçons on expliquera comment on
peut mener cette histoire bien cher
philippe très heureux d'être dans cette
campagne très heureux d'être côtés de
mon camarade laurent wauquiez nous avons
été ensemble du gouvernement
nous sommes ensemble à régions de france
et nous sommes ensemble pour défendre
une sertie d une certaine idée de la
france et de l'europe
mais nous sommes aussi nous centristes
très heureux d'être là parce que nous
sommes avec un candidat c'est la
dernière fois que je te le dis parce que
c'est le dernier meeting de l'année avec
un candidat comme nous l'avons tous déjà
dit qui est une étoile extraordinaire
dans le ciel de la vie politique
française
c'est
françoise aviez bellamy
tu es allé sur internet moi je l' ai
beaucoup écouté et quand je j'ai entendu
sa belle et jolie voix qui résonne de la
profondeur de sa pensée de
l'intelligence il est capable d'apporter
dans un débat politique
bien souvent si mécanique et si réflexes
et bien je me suis dit qu'avec françois
xavier bellamy nous avions une belle
voix une belle intelligence pour
défendre nos idées et nos valeurs et ça
c'est un immense bonheur que de pouvoir
soutenir ou tout du moins de porter
cette candidature
absolument exceptionnel car elle
démontre une seule chose mesdames et
messieurs c'est que les anciennes
formations politiques sont aussi
capables de générer et de déceler des
talents exceptionnels
contrairement à la petite ritournelle
qu'on nous a raconté pendant deux ans
donc avec françoise avis et bellamy nous
avons le meilleur bond au parlement
européen
alors je suis très heureux aussi
mesdames et messieurs parce que j'ai le
sentiment d'être en cohérence avec moi
même je vais à peu près toujours été
dans la vie politique mais je le suis
plus encore durant cette campagne pour
une raison extrêmement simple mesdames
et monsieur parce que la question qu'on
aurait pu se poser qu'est ce que nous
centristes nouveau centre aurions pu
nous faire aurions nous pu faire
est ce que nous aurions pu faire notre
liste j'invite simplement mon camarade
jean christophe lagarde élégie dei qui
se posent la question de voter utile de
voter pour nous plutôt pour une liste
qui va faire 1 % nous aurions pu faire
un autre choix comme d'autres l'ont fait
et moi je me suis simplement posé deux
questions la première mesdames et
messieurs avec qui sommes nous dans les
villes avec qui sommes nous dans les
départements avec qui sommes nous dans
les régions nous sommes avec les
républicains et en cohérence
il nous fallait porter le même combat
politique au moment des européennes car
nous serons ensemble on ne ment des
municipales départementales et
régionales comme nous le sommes
aujourd'hui dans les majorités
départementales ou régionales
la schizophrénie très peu pour nous et
mes chers amis y avait au moins
derrière cette candidature commune
une autre idée l'idée que
progressivement nous puissions
apparaître pour nos compatriotes comme
une alternative crédible dans les
combats futurs
vous le savez emmanuel macron a essayé
d'enfermer le débat démocratique dans un
choix sable front national ou moi eh
bien les français sont en train de lui
dire qu'on enferme pas la france dans un
débat binaire
qu'on enferme pas la démocratie dans un
choix qui on le sait est un choix qui
serait suicidaire et qu'il y a la
possibilité d'une nouvelle expression
démocratique d'une nouvelle majorité et
que cette majorité là nous sommes en
train de la voir émerger
nous avons planté une graine et bientôt
nous aurons les fruits parce que nous
apparaîtrons comme l'alternative
crédible aux français au moment des
prochaines élections
et je vous invite simplement à faire ce
petit calcul
je n'y avais pas pensé jusqu'à l'or mais
moi c'est probablement les reliait qui
me permet d'être un peu plus réfléchi ou
de me poser d'autres questions
emmanuel macron a fait de cette campagne
un combat quasi personnel faut dire
qu'il a choisi une très bonne tête de
liste ce qui prouve à quel point il a
beaucoup de lucidité
mais au-delà de cette histoire posez
vous cette question quand les sondages
créditent la liste en marge de 20 à 22%
oh ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il
ya 80% qui aujourd'hui n'approuvent pas
la politique du gouvernement et du
président de la république et posez vous
une seconde question
il arrive à faire 20% avec le soutien et
la détermination d'un gouvernement qui
fait des annonces toutes les 24 heures
et qui charge lourd la barque sans se
préoccuper des déficits en se disant que
à travers cela on va pouvoir peut-être
grappiller quelques demi pourcent
supplémentaire en ayant fait venir à lui
dans la même liste des socialistes
dernier soutien en date
ségolène royal
en faisant venir d'anciens europe
ecologie les verts qui tout d'un coup en
trouver la lumière chez en marche
comme ce qu'enfin et en ayant aussi
ouvert largement salissent à d'anciens
amis il a comme soutien le modem ça fait
longtemps les doigts mais il a le
soutien d' agir il a le soutien des jus
pays
il a le soutien d'un ancien premier
ministre de jacques chirac et en ayant
rassemblé et rassembler toutes ces
formations politiques et tous ces
courants et bien mesdames et messieurs
on le crédite de 20 % aux élections
européennes et vous voyez bien qu'à
travers ce score probable il ya un appel
à autre chose et cette autre chose je
veux que nous puissions l'incarner dans
les prochaines années
alors le second sujet je voudrais
évoquer très rapidement parce que j'ai
promis à laurent et françoise aviez de
ne pas dépasser mon temps de parole
c'est le message que cherche à porter le
prix en la république en nous disant je
vais vous refonder l'europe
je vais vous rebâtir une autre europe
une europe puissance une europe capable
de porter de grandes stratégies capables
d'assurer le développement du continent
européen
et la question que je voudrais vous
poser ses mais avec qui avec qui jamais
mesdames et messieurs la france n'a été
aussi isolé sur le théâtre européen
quand monsieur macron nous fait l'europe
dont il rêve
dans ce discours de la sorbonne j'ai
profité du train pour essayer de lister
toutes les propositions qu'il avait pu
faire alors j'ai pas j'ai pas vous
allonger la liste
mais je vous défie je vous défie de
trouver une seule proposition qui a fait
le début d'une réalisation
il parle d'un office européen de l'asile
il n'en a n'est toujours pas question
il parle de hotspot pour réguler
l'immigration
nous les attendons toujours il parle
d'un plan stratégique de développement
pour le continent africain porté par
l'union européenne il n'en n'est
toujours pas question
il parle d'harmonisation fiscale et
sociale
bien malin le pays européens qui
voudraient nous tendre la main ou bien
inconscient le pays européens qui
voudraient nous tendre la main pour
amener ses impôts au niveau des
prélèvements obligatoires qu'ils nous
inflige
chaque année à travers une hausse
infinie des prélèvements obligatoires
il nous parle d'harmonisation sociale en
évoquant la question des travailleurs
détachés mais ce qu'il a pu obtenir des
états européens sur les travailleurs des
tâches en détacher c'est tout simplement
un faux semblant
il nous a expliqué que grâce à sa
réforme on avait désormais travail égal
salaire égal
sauf que mesdames et messieurs il a
oublié de parler des cotisations
sociales et donc il n'y a toujours pas
travail égal salaire égal pour les
travailleurs détachés
il évoque mesdames et messieurs la
nécessité d'un grand plan pour
l'environnement il évoque la question
d'une taxe carbone à l'échelle
européenne
elle n'est toujours pas arrivé et moi ce
que je sais en revanche c'est ce que me
disait un grand acteur industriel de la
métallurgie
il y à une quinzaine de jours dans ma
région qui grâce à l'augmentation de la
taxe carbone décidée par le gouvernement
paie 25 millions d'euros de plus de
contributions ce qui l'amène globalement
à considérer qu'une année
d'investissements passe simplement dans
la contribution complémentaire
je pourrais continuer indéfiniment
mais mesdames et messieurs il n'y a
aucun sujet sur lesquels le chef de
l'état peut nous dire qu'il est capable
de faire bouger l'europe et ça c'est une
grande innovation dans l'histoire de ces
cinquante dernières années
souvenez vous des grands couples qui ont
fait la construction européenne de
gaulle adenauer giscard schmitt chirac
fraudeurs kohl mitterrand sarkozy merkel
est ce que on pourrait dire aujourd'hui
qu'au nom de madame merkel
on pourrait s'y associer monsieur macron
eh bien vous voyez bien qu'il n'ya plus
aujourd'hui de moteur européen capable
de transformer l'europe et que le schéma
européen que propose le président de la
république il n'est partagée par
personne
c'est ça la réalité et je termine sur un
sujet parce que si je ne le fais pas
françoise aviez me reproche de ne pas en
parler c'est la question de l'armée
européenne
chers amis nous avons eu un président de
la république qui nous a dit il faut une
armée robert j'ai envie de lui dire mais
avec qui philippe tous les pays
européens ont démissionné sur leurs
ambitions de défense et de sécurité
tous les pays européens sans exception
on chez rita ont confié leur sécurité à
l'alliance atlantique
et quand nous voulons mener une
opération avec les européens
nous trouvons la plupart du temps tout
seul pour assurer ou essayer de faire en
sorte qu'une partie du continent
africain ne soit pas déstabiliser comme
nous l'avons vécu au mali il y a
quelques années
chers amis tous les instruments existent
il existe des forces de réaction rapide
il existe un état major à travers l'état
major de leur corps mais mesdames et
messieurs tous ces instruments qui
existent n'ont jamais été mises en
oeuvre pour une raison simple c'est qu'
aucun pays européen n'a de volonté pour
faire en sorte que l'europe s'affirme
comme une puissance et pire encore
mesdames et messieurs ce que nous
devrions défendre et j'espère françoise
aviez qu'avec ta liste vous le défendre
et je n'ai aucun doute avec arnaud
danjean que cela soit fait ce ne soit
pas fait c'est
au contraire de bâtir une base
industrielle et technologique de défense
pour que nous ne soyons plus sous la
dépendance des américains lorsque nous
décidons d'exporter du matériel de
guerre dans un certain nombre de pays il
faut que vous sachiez parce que jamais
on en parle
lorsque nous vendons des armes à
l'arabie saoudite ou à l'egypte nous
sommes obligés de demander l'accord aux
états unis puisqu'il y a un certain
nombre de composants qui sont des
composants américains
et bien si on voulait être sérieux sur
ces sujets on éviterait de raconter des
fables qui font plaisir aux français
comme celui ou celle de l'armée
européenne mais au contraire de leur
dire ce dont on a besoin c'est d'une
base industrielle et technologique de
défense pour assurer notre souveraineté
et notre sécurité
et j'ajoute mesdames et messieurs que
sur la défense
s'il ya bien un sujet que je ne veux pas
confier aux européens c'est bien celui
ci
ma défense ma sécurité ultime elle
dépend de la nation française et elle
dépend uniquement d'un pouvoir politique
est à paris et qui n'est pas je me
saisis à bruxelles à strasbourg ou
ailleurs je ne laisserai jamais ma
défense et la sécurité dans les mains
des hollandais des italiens ou des
espagnols quelle que soit l'amitié que
je peux avoir pour eux et si monsieur
mac on voulait vraiment assurer notre
sécurité
il serait aussi inspiré de faire en
sorte que nous ne soyons pas
progressivement nous en europe une
colonie sur les questions du numérique
dépendant progressivement de l'ensemble
des grands opérateurs que vous
connaissez et que vous utilisez tous les
jours qui nous amène dans une situation
de vassalité absolu sur ces questions
sans qu'à aucun moment les européens ne
réagisse voilà mesdames et messieurs les
vrais sujets de cette campagne
européenne
voilà les vrais sujets que porte
françois xavier et toute sa liste
alors mesdames et messieurs il nous
reste quatre jours quatre jours pour
dire aux français que la droite et le
centre sont de retour parce que derrière
cette histoire là il ya quelque chose
que nous sommes en train de construire
nous sommes en train de construire le
noyau dur qui permettra progressivement
à tous les électrons qui sont encore en
liberté de venir nous rejoindre parce
qu'ils auront compris que c'est le début
de la reconstruction de la refondation
et de la réapparition de la droite et du
centre
oui nous sommes faits pour être ensemble
parce que nous portons les mêmes valeurs
parce que nous défendons l'idée de
responsabilité parce que nous défendons
l'idée d'une gestion rigoureuse de la
dépense publique et parce que nous
défendons la liberté d'entreprise et la
liberté de création
et donc oui mesdames et messieurs au
soir de cette élection européenne grâce
au talent de françoise aviez bellamy
nous pourrons dire la droite et le
centre est sont de retour dans la vie
politique française jean merci
[Applaudissements]